We bought this old rusty pig trailer
to turnit into a tiny house.
What do you think about it?
- It's rough.
In the previous videos, you could see us
strippingit and putting in the walls.
In this video, we're going to make it waterproof.
And,we're also going to continue
clearing the road, that we started last week.
Just so we can havean emergency exit in case of wildfires.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update.
Okay, it's time to getstarted inside the trailer!
However, we noticed it's not that easy to get into...
Yeah, we could usea stairs before getting started.
- So, that's why we need the ladder.
Here, we have our beautifulladder or stairs
that we found at the scrapyard.
Since it's needing of a bit of atouchup,
we'll cut it at a right degree angle.
And then, we'll most likely weld plates to it,
so we can secure that.
It shouldn't be too much trouble.
It's going to be a fun one!
What areyou doing up there?
- I'm setting up a GoPro for you!
Thank you!
- I don't know if you know this Robert,
but it'sa bit too high...
A little bit!
- But, it's okay.
For now, we're going to just make
two posts here withbeams and another step.
So, yeah, let's make that.
- The ladder is in place and itfeels sturdy.
Let's go to the next step!
Okay, so, we want to start putting the roofin.
But, for that, we have to put this vapor barrier and install it.
Also, we have to finishthe windows and the door.
So, we are going to be doing
two processes at the same time.
Twopeople are going to be working on the roof.
One is going to be finishing the windows.
So, yeah...
Westart setting up the foil for the insulation,
that we will add later.
We are going to try out a new kind of material.
Insulation made out of old textile and clothes.
It seems like a nice wayto reuse use those materials!
But, the downside is that this material
cannot get wet, or elseit will get moldy...
So, we need to add this new waterproof layer
or vapor barrier, to make sure itstays dry.
It feels nice to use recycled materials,
but we don't like adding this new foil...
Let us knowwhat you think about it in the comments section.
Anyway, for now, we're going to give this a try.
Well, let's see if we can even manage with this wind...
So, we're struggling a bit!
The wind isjust blowing the tarp into the trailer all the time!
And, it's throwing our GoPro off.
So, Ithink we're going to start folding
and then we just finish this last part here.
Because,it's just impossible with the wind...
Now that the foil is all rolledup,
Wouter can continue with the windows.
- All right! The foil is in!
We have little waterrepellent edge, so the water cannot run in.
But, still, there was a bit of hole here, which would leak.
So, I will patch it with some leftovers.
I will put it behind the other foil,
so when water runs from here, it will run off.
Just so it doesn't creep in between this two layers.
- We got this aluminium sheet,
when we were strippingthe trailer before.
It was on the back of the door.
It's a bit too hard to reuse this.
It'sall bended and bumpy...
We're going to use smaller parts
to make the edges of the windows.
This will make sure the rain water will flow out.
- So, this is the first rafter we're going to putin.
We have the vapor barrier.
We're going tostart putting the rafters in.
The first one.
- So, what are we doing here?
We're going to even out the beams.
We just put all the rafters in.
But, we didn't really measure it,
if they are all sticking out the same amount.
Or, the same size...
So, right now, I'm going tomark this first beam
at 10 centimeters, and then the last one there.
I'll drive a nail in.
Wedon't have a chalk line, but we can use rope.
We'll put the rope and just mark all the beams at thesame size.
So, yeah...
It's much faster.
- Sounds good!
Some video maker advice!
Always keep aneye out that the microphone is NOT in the frame.
- Right now, this line is straight.
The beams are sticking out a bit.
So, we're going to mark them and cut them off.
It took a while to cut all the tips of therafters.
But finally, they are in.
As a next step, we will be putting wood boards
on top, while alsoplacing the windows
But, for all that, we first needed to get materials.
We want to make this trailer with
as much secondhand materials as possible.
But, it's quite hardto find old things around here...
Especially if you look for sturdy decent things.
Therejust aren't many people or companies doing this.
So, it always takes quite some timeto find some.
But, we found a few places
close by that might have something!
So, let'shave a look!
First up: a place with wooden windows.
We found the first one, butunfortunately,
they didn't have much at this place...
So, let's try another place to find the rest.
- Let's find some windows for the pig trailer.
Most people in Portugal have aluminum
frames in the windows.
Wefound a place where they make windows,
but they also replace windows.
So, they have leftovers or secondhand windows.
But, they also have here a
stash of old wooden window windows.
They just use it to burn it in the
workspace to heat up during the winter.
- They don'tlike wood?
They don't like wood, like the old times.
We found some windows here.
Jackpot!
These are our new windows, guys.
We're going to get this, this and this.
A fine glass insulation.
Let's see what they look like!
- We need to get some wood for the inside.
So, we're back at the sawmill!
Let's get some more of that basketball court.
You might remember that we have already
used these boards from an old basketball court.
This was during the renovating of the yellow van.
Luckily, they still have a big amount of it!
It actuallyseems that no one around here
really likes to work with it...
Since, it's not the easiestto work with.
It's so sketchy!
The amount is still the same as before, so that's good forus.
The only downside is that the good ones are at the bottom...
So, we are choosing all the boards.
It's difficultto find boards that are without lines and stuff.
So, we stopped being picky about that.
But, we finallyfound out where the basketball court is from!
It's from Tondela.
Now that we have all the materialswe need,
it's time to place the windows we just got.
At the same time, we are alsoworking on the basketball roof.
We're getting close to make thebig trailer ready for some rain.
Here we are on our beautiful roof!
Yesterdaywas a really productive day!
We finished quite a lot.
We have just this last piecehere to fill up.
We're going to do that this morning.
And then, we are going to cutoff the edges
and square up the roof.
So, we didn't measure the lengthof the boards.
Because, I can now cut everything off with the tracksaw.
So, I'm going to measure
and mark up where I have to cut.
I'll cut everythingoff flush with this beam of the tracksaw.
I think that's enough.
So, we're going to finish putting the vapor barrier on.
We're going to put it on top
and seal it with aluminum tape.
As fastas possible too, because this thing gets hot fast!
Okay, so, welcome to a closed pig trailer.
Finally, the pig trail is almost waterproof.
We installed three old aluminium windows anda big wooden one.
They all have double glass and a little aluminium strip
on the bottom toguide the water away.
We also installed a big old wooden door.
We've put the rafters on the roofthat hold up
the basketball court from the close by town.
As you can see, it still has some stickerson it from gym.
We also installed the stairs at the entrance.
And, we have installed the foil onthe walls.
It's still rolled up as we have to put the insulation first.
But, you will see that inthe next updates.
Subscribe and follow to see how we continue!
- All right, so, nice work on the pig trailer!
We'll continue working on that.
But, for now, we're going to finish up the road.
We started this a fewweeks ago.
We have cleaned the left side of the road for a fire exit.
So, in case everything burnsdown, we can safely go out.
And now, we're going to continue cleaning the right side.
It's very similar!
It also has a lot of mimosas and a lot of spiky bushes.
But, a big difference is that it also has a lot
ofnative trees and a nice view from our big old ruin.
So, it should give a good end result!
But, it'sgoing to be a lot of work...
So, we're going to get some help.
- Okay, it's still early in the morning.
Somefriends are going to come, because we have some friends
locally living that really are willingto help.
So, we invited them for today,
and we will take on the second half of the road.
First, a hotdrink while gathering together,
and then we're going to start!
Okay, today is the day that we're going
totake down these big mimosas.
Because, in the back, there are many nature of trees
that we wantto give priority to.
So, these ones are going to go down.
- Morning!
We now have a different approach!
Because, we can'tcut the trees so they will fall over this road.
They will always fall back.
So, that's what we'regoing to do.
We're going to cut the trees,
and make them smaller when they're down.
I'm going toclear this first and then we can work.
As you can see, the job went well!
All of theoaks are nice, healthy and intact!
So, it works nice.
It could have be worse, but at the end,
you can see the end result of those two.
- What's happening Ale?
I have brambles, sawdustand Mimosas all over the place, so...
Every once in a while you have to clean
abit, because it's too much.
- Some mimosas are very big like this one,
which just got cut down.
This oneis going to Hans to be used as firewood, I think.
- So, another day, another job done!
You can see that nomimosas are around!
Now, we have a nice and clear space.
- The rest of the areato clear was mainly a brush cutting job.
It's nothing too special,but it's somehow satisfying to watch!
- Okay guys, so, we recently finished the right side of theroad.
Let me show you the results now!
So, where I'm walking right now, you couldn't make a move.
Youcouldn't get here!
This was all fully overgrown!
Brambles, ferns and multiple kinds of bushes.
But, as youcan see, the space is fully open now.
Only the natives remain, which is very coolfor them to thrive!
We found or rediscovered these fruit trees.
We planted these lastyears,
but they didn't have any space to grow...
Now, they are free and happy.
So, downhere after this slope,
we did loads and loads of brush cutting here!
And now, it's just clean,neat and nice.
This area we also brush cutted a lot!
We had to do some manual work
to free upthe natives as well.
Right now, we have the neighbors biological brush cutters.
All right,so, we tackled clearing the sides of the roads.
We had a lot of mimosas, brambles
and bushesto defeat, but we won!
And, now that the job is done...
As you can see, it's beautiful.
So, we canenjoy the scenery, while going back to Basekamp.
- The road is now cleaned up
It's now much safer in caseof a fire.
We also freed up the native trees,
so they can grow into big trees now, which is cool.
And, in general, the whole land here is now much easier to maintain!
Because, we can just keepit low
with a brush cutter, so it doesn't get wild again.
Now, we got a lot of mimosas,
andwe're going to give the office a little upgrade!
It's involving one of the favoritethings of you guys: Kevin!
We're going to use the mimosas, some old jeans
and a sewing machineto make something useful.
It's been a hot summer in Kamp.
The windows let the sun getin
and it heats up the whole office!
We tried putting cork on the windows
and the principleworks, but...
This setup feels too improvised.
So, we thought: ''Let's make some curtains.''
We'regoing to use some of the mimosas that we cut before.
The first stem will be usedas a bar,
so we make sure it's smooth.
With the second trunk,
we willcreate the support for the main bar.
- So, we have this jeans material
leftover from the previous project.
And, we are going to make a curtain out of it for the office.
It's done!
- So, now we have some nice thick curtains.
They really keep the sun outside,
so it prevents the building from heating up.
Which is good, becausemakes it a bit
more comfortable to work here.
All right, so, that was it for this video!
In the next video, we're going to continue working on the pig trailer.
And, we're going tobuild something special!
It's a special episode, because it's number 100!
If you already want to see that,
make sure to subscribe to our Patreon!
You can seeit one week ahead!
Or not, and just subscribe on YouTube.
You can then see it next week.
Samechannel, same time!
Thank you for watching!
Ciao!